à
la sortie du collège au pied des élèves
pas d'entorse au règlement tous en
basket pas de claquettes chaussettes la
consigne est écrite noir sur blanc les
claquettes chaussettes sont interdits
une précision qui figure depuis
plusieurs années au règlement intérieur
de ce collège de saint denis
certainement dépassés par une mode qui
fait fureur jusque dans les clips de rap
peut pas venir en claquettes à au
collège c'est pour les vacances pour moi
c'est ridicule c'est une tenue
appropriée c'est drôle parce que c'est
juste des claquettes en fait rien rien
de grave on va les pieds nus ça leur
servent à quoi de savoir s'ils ont peur
des claquettes chaussettes pas bien
c'est pas comme si on avait ramené une
arme à l'école mais celle impossible
regarde un peu à quoi ressemble-t-il zot
va pas modérer sa me disant
on aime bien les ch'ti
franchement j'adore parce que c'est tout
ce que j'aime il ya tout tout vous ne
représentez voilà les legends
ou non mais c'est vrai voilà des gens
qui voient là qui arrivent des gens qui
repartent les chefs jean vit ce soit
vraiment qu'on soit tous unis main dans
la main parce que ça c'est ça c'est la
france vous avez le choix l'essentiel
c'est que on découvre votre personnalité
à travers votre gâteau au chocolat bon
si vous ne lisez pas la première
cuillère moi je me défonce
[Rires]
[Musique]
ne me dis pas que tu cuisines ici voici
les femmes la cuisinière choqué
c'est un truc de ouf
tu veux pas me dire que tu cuisines là
dedans bah si j'ai une voix d'une
mauvaise nouvelle la mauvaise nouvelle
en effet c'est que vous allez partir la
bonne nouvelle c'est que vous allez
pouvoir revenir puisque n'avait pas
dépassé les dix mille euros de gains
vous serez toujours la bienvenue parce
qu'il ya un potentiel aussi de rentrer
jeudi à nagui elle me fait peur donc oui
ça mais vous parlez du maquillage à ce
moment là mais c'est vrai que georges la
base mais attendez donc un bon j'ai un
peu déçu parce que je pense que j'aurais
pu apporter beaucoup à ma famille mais
je leur en veux pas on coince un moment
pour tout genre de plus l'humidité j'ai
hâte de te retrouver ma vie françois
hollande a flingué la politique d'
emmanuel macron en pleine crise est ce
que c'est le rôle d'un président sylvain
cormier de françois hollande donne des
conseils tu peux être sûr que tu as
réussi ta vie alors oui c'est vrai c'est
comme si c'est quand même un ennemi il a
tout raté on sait même pas qu'il est
président il se prend elle permet de
donner des conseils à pierre paul et
jacques lui bon c'est qu'à manger des
flancs à l'elysée avec assad non mais
lui c'est un gilet tous les jours et
léché le quotidien et les limites
chroniqueur rabat et d'apprendre à bien
fait des voix pour des dessins animés
bientôt on va le retrouver dans
matzinger sommes le 7 septembre date à
laquelle sont mêlés plus grand marcel
desailly matthieu gonet le chanteur père
paul jacques ou encore patrick cohen
la patrouille
hélas le gâteau d'anniversaire de la fed
funds et damas ah oui
anniversaire dit cadeau je le montre
avec caméra il
se fait rattraper par
un petit cadeau première contre je
voulais pas lui donner maintenant parce
que maman ça fait du genre je laisse un
peu
pantois la river donne des leçons
allemagne vda crochet au père emmanuel
macron un produit qui donne des leçons
le gars il a été président plus personne
quand soudain il arrive dans un
restaurant une limite on ne fait même
pas rentrer mais le gars il est content
mais sans déconner mais pour les gens
françois hollande c'est un fromage
maintenant ça y est le gars se permet de
donner des leçons à tout le monde comme
si c'était un génie bah écoute bravo
françois hollande franchement il ya des
candidats
c'est les boules de pétanque n'a pas été
facile à convaincre mais ton meilleur
ami un message pour ton anniversaire non
[Musique]
eh bien il ya plus de gens qui va autour
de leur date anniversaire
tout comme on en a besoin a toujours une
bonne en dehors centre ya aucun problème
je suis trop contente d'être là
j'ai pas envie de me retenir de rigoler
à tes blagues lotus que tu me fais trop
rire donc c est tout il ya c'est vrai
parfois très drôles toi tu trouves pas
que j'ai augmenté niveau niveau on peut
encore le conjuguer d'euros liteo ça se
jouerait super terre arrête
arrête tu es marié était bien le monde
reste les gens travaillent et non mais
c'est vrai tu as eu cinq ans pour faire
le boulot et était même pas représenté
derrière c'est comme s'il était un des
gars tu es champion du monde là l'équipe
championne et moins a dit non je n'ai
pas la coupe du monde l'année d'après
tellement je sais que je vais prendre
une tôle non mais c'est incroyable la
mort de juste jacquin il était le
réalisateur du film culte emmanuel est
décédé hier à l'âge de 82 ans ce film
érotique avait été le plus gros succès
de l'année 1974 avec le 9 millions
d'entrées le début d'une saga merci juge
a qu'un le pastis sans alcool c'est
comme emmanuel la différence entre les
films érotiques et les films le x10 la
loi c'est que dans les films érotiques
il n'y a pas pénétration visible en tout
cas
[Rires]